So now that we've talked about all the elements of a good experimental study,
let's put it all together into an experiment. So what we're going to do is
begin our experiment the way all psychology experiments do. By getting the
informed consent from our participants. Informed consent means that the
participant is aware of all the requirements of the study and agrees to
participate. Once they've given us consent. We decided we're going to randomly
put our participants into groups by flipping a coin to ensure that it's
randomly assigned. Because this is a single blind study, we know who's going to
be in the control group and we know who's going to be in the experimental
group. In the experimental group again, is those who get caffeine. In the
control group, they don't get caffeine. Everything other than the independent
variable has to be the same in both groups. So, our next step is to measure
their reaction time. To do this, we use a reaction time test online. When the
screen changes from white to black, the participant has to click. We took the
average of five trials from each participant. You can try this test on your own
by clicking the link below.